الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تركت تداعيات
سياسيه واقتصاديه وامنيه على باكستان التي
دفعت ثمنا سياسيا باهضا باسقاط حكومه
عمران خان التي حاولت التزام الحياد
فجاءتها الضربه من تملم الباكستانيين بسبب
ارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه بمعدل تجاوز
30% شهريا تم سحب الثقه من الحكومه ثم
تلتها محاوله اغتيال خانه ودخلت البلاد في
معركه سياسيه طاحنه
للاسف زياره رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان لروسيا كانت لها تداعيات سياسيه في
باكستان
بعض معارضيه حزبه قالوا ان توقيت الزياره
لم يكن مناسبا
والامم المتحده لم يرق لها ذلك
من المعارضه واطيح به من الحكم
مستويات غير مسبوقه من التضخم يشهدها
الاقتصاد الباكستاني وصلت الى حوالي
ثلاثين في المئه ركود صناعي تراجع في
الصادرات شح في احتياطي العمله الصعبه وكل
ذلك اثر على فرص العمل المعروضه
تاثرنا بشكل كبير في العام الماضي بنسبه
6% كما ان الفيضانات سددت نقصا في الاغذيه
لقد اعتدنا استيراد المواد الغذائيه
والاوليه من روسيا واوكرانيا وهذا تاثير
سلبي ايضا
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا اجبرت باكستان
على اعاده حساباتها الدفاعيه وتحالفاتها
الاستراتيجيه من جديد
الحرب الاوكرانيه دفعت باكستان الى ادراك
ان هناك حدا للتوقعات والتعاون العسكري مع
قوه واحده
فهي في حاجه الى بناء توازن بين امريكا
والصين
تؤكد باكستان ان لهذه الحرب عواقب بعيده
المدى على عدد من القضايا الاقليميه كضبط
التسلح ومنع الانتشار النووي وامن الطاقه